that was a huge sum of money so I'm
wealthy again I said
wellow what a great country America is I
just can't get over this country you can
fall on your ass and you can get up and
do it again wow huh it's a really good
thing you grew up where Colin grew up in
uh North Queensland
Australia
my people had a cattle property
there what year was that that was um I
was born in 1942 and I I stayed on and
off the cattle property until I was into
my early teens and then I went then I
went South with my to live with my dad
and and my mother and he was quite an
entrepreneur he built an ice
works and um I one of one of seven kids
the oldest son and I have three brothers
and three
sisters and it was uh it was a great
time in
Australia we had a cattle property that
was so small it was
laughable but it was 500 square miles it
was laughably
small but it was um it was a good time
uh my only problem was uh I couldn't
speak properly I had a very bad
speech impediment I started incredibly
badly for reasons I didn't really
understand and nobody understood
anything in those days of course if you
had something wrong with you or they
just said we'll take an aspirin and fix
that so that's basically what happened
to me and uh so I was throwing out of
schools all over the place and this went
to a little country town on the rim of
the outb back when my dad built an ice
works and in those days it was
[Music]
pre-referendum he lost patience with me
and I don't blame him he was such a
wonderful
man uh and he says you got to get out of
here and I'm 14 years old and I said uh
yeah well probably a good idea he said
you've been thrown out of every school
they don't want to see you in school
anymore he said you don't learn anything
you're as thick as a brick and I says
yeah well and I'm starting and
stammering and I said well okay so I got
him a horse had a horse called
Queenie which uh we're now down in the
SLE town of marba on the rim of the
Outback had left the cattle property and
uh my dad hated horses he thought
they're the stupidest thing in the world
which caused a lot of friction between
he and I because I love horses and I had
this horse called
Queeny uh and a a guy called Henry Shaw
who was trying to make race horses and
he had Queeny as a um a pacing horse he
called it where he he would ride Queeny
and bring the race horses along and and
uh get them conditioned to try and run
him around the track but Queenie wasn't
fast enough so one day out of fit of
anger he said to me Colin he says take
this stupid horse before I put a bullet
in his head I said yeah okay so I took
Queenie at about the same time Dad
decided I should get out of the house
cuz I was too much trouble and I said
don't blame you so I got on Queeny and
I'm 14 years old haven't been to school
for about 4 years 3 years every every
time I'd go to school it would be a
disaster cuz I couldn't talk properly
and get into fights and and I learned to
box pretty good uh I went to one of
those there was a boxing troop called
the Jimmy Shaman boxing troop and they
had these little country sort of fairs
and so I went I put my hand up at the
Jimmy Shaman boxing troop and I only
ever had one trick in those days but it
was a good one some of had pick me and
want to punch my lights out and I'd say
ah funny shoes you wearing aren't they
they'd looked down boom it was an
uppercut right there with a powerful
uppercut right left left end of the side
down goes ahead another uppercut boom
they're out so was there was no problem
at all I thought this is easy that's all
you got to do but anyhow so you know it
was school for me was a very bad very
bad thing well my problem was I couldn't
speak I try to make sentences and words
had just run together and uh people
thought I was an
idiot uh and uh I probably sounded like
an idiot so I got on Queeny and in this
little town of
marba and uh rode out 30 miles to a
place called Patty's
green and Patty's green was uh just a
desolate
area euphemistically called Patty's
green what nothing green about it but
there was a lagoon there that I that I
that I was aware of so I thought this is
great now when I was a kid on the on the
cattle property I played with the
aboriginals the Aboriginal children and
uh they they were pretty reticent about
me playing with them because I was stark
white and they're black black black
Australian aboriginals are not just
black they're blue black they're the
blackest black you ever saw in your life
you know they talk about Americans being
black and I look at black people here
and they look white to me but there
they're black black black and uh so the
Aboriginal kids used to just laugh at me
and say ha you know so I'd cover myself
all in mud take all my clothes off put
them up in a tree cover myself all in
mud have a lime cloth on covered that in
mud too and I'm totally covered in mud
and then they could accept me then I'm
playing with them all the time and and
uh learned to throw Spears and I was I
was pretty good with the spear I was
better than any of they were very and
them were and I could knock and I could
do pretty good with the
boomerang so I was uh I was very happy
about that
life but um and not being able to talk
didn't matter with the Aboriginal kids
but now transposed years later on I'm in
this little town of marba I'm 14 years
old dad's kicked me out I got a lot of
problems with well got school is just a
disaster so I get on my horse called
Queenie she was a mayor a a a Whitey
sort of Mayor and um rote her out to
this Patty's green that I remembered
seeing at one time and uh took off all
my clothes like I used to way back when
made a line clo put the clothes up in a
tree and uh thought this is great this
is
fantastic there's nobody
around so this is just marvelous
marvelous just I was so
ecstatic and uh there's a lagoon right
there and I check out the Lagoon and I
see fish in it oh this is good so I I
just passed coming in ID passed a wire
fence fenced off by some cattle guy I
guess so I got some Stones together cut
off three hunks of wire banging Stones
together and U found a long bamboo pole
shoved the sticks up in that sharpened
them on the stone and started and
speared fish out of the Lagoon and uh I
could light a fire with the stick as
quickly as anybody else could with a
match so little fire got that gone put
the fish in that thought wow wow this is
the life Wow nobody out here to bug me
wow I'm completely free wow so now I I
got uh made us made another spear out of
uh found a hunk of there was a cattle
yard not too far from there and so there
was a old gate that had fallen over but
I found a bolt out of that and I I I
spent hours making a point on the bolt
then I strapped that to a long Pole
and that was going to be my wabby Spear
and I speared a wabby with it very
easily what shocked me most of all was
that
um I'd approached wab bees before many
many times and they all ran away but now
I'm more covered in mud and they didn't
run away they accepted me as one of them
I thought wellow this is so cool I like
this so I'm looking to wabby in the eye
and then of course I felt a bit bad
about spearing the damn thing but I
thought well I'm hungry so this WABE is
out of here so wab are small kangaroos
about 2 feet high 3T high so I'd
um uh ripped its guts
out reminded myself I got to find a
knife from someplace didn't have a knife
so I just um ran my hand up its butt
ripped it ripped the guts open like that
dropped all the guts out put the WABE in
in the coals I just left it there all
day and um covered it with some banana
Palm leaves that were readily on the
bank
there came back that night after messing
around and there it was a beautifully
cooked WABE I open it out it's just
beautiful steaming
ah this was so good and uh so it was uh
it was a very very good time there and
uh so I've got Queenie tied beside
me and I said to Queenie I said well
what do you think of this
Quinny is this better than where you
were in that stupid old stable with the
Henry Shaw is beating the crap out of
you cuz you couldn't go fast enough I
says works for me here I hope it's
working for you and so I had a few
conversations with
Queenie and uh this went on for a couple
of weeks
and I'm really really becoming one with
this whole situation I loved it loved it
and uh so I'm talking to Queeny and then
it occurred to me I said wait a minute I
can talk to Queeny like people talk to
each other said wow and I was stunned at
this Revelation you weren't stuttering
weren't
stuttering
and what the trick was I think what did
it for me was that I had to that I spoke
slowly to Queenie thinking that she
needed uh slow speech otherwise she
wouldn't understand what I was saying
ridiculous but uh so I'm talking to
Queeny I'd say hello Queenie how are you
today stuff like this said wait a minute
I can say that even a bit faster hello
Queenie how are you today oh that's
pretty good so I'm really stoked with
this idea so I said yeah this is good
this is good
so
um I got um I'm in there about 3 weeks
in the bush and uh thought well my
mother said that she was going to hang
up a sugar bag full of supplies for me
on this little country road that was
nearby about 30 mil from where the
Lagoon was so I said quenny we're going
out to see what Mother's dropped hung up
in that tree for me she told me where
the gum tree was at the at the at the
fork of the road there sure enough I go
there and there's the there's there's
the sugar bag that she had left me and
it had flour in it self raising flour uh
tea uh sugar uh pepper salt and uh
several clothes of garlic and I thought
wow this is pretty good most of all she
had put had a couple of 10 plates in
there and knives and forks I thought gee
I'll be I'll be in the Hilton Hotel
right here this will be well I didn't
have a Hilton hotel then but but I'll be
in some of other those fancy tourist
hotels so
um go back and see this is marvelous
this is great so another week or we week
goes by and I thought well I'm going to
go and see if mother's got that sugar
bag there again I can do with some more
self-raising flour I'd made what I call
a damper I'd figured out how to make it
with the self-raising flour wet it put
salt in it put that and in the coals
take it out to be black look like a
black cylinder but if you cut it smoke
came out of this beautiful bread oh man
it was so good so good well was hungry
most of the time so I guess that was one
reason it tasted so
good um so it was uh very enjoyable and
I thought to myself yeah so I ride back
out again to see what mother might have
hung something back on the tree for me
and to my surprise a little old beat up
truck comes
along and it stops and my first instinct
was to run first of all the police are
looking for me I'm a
runaway I'm
considered halfway dangerous because I
did I did break a few noses and put a
few teeth down people's
throats uh because they they made fun of
me um and uh I thought no I can't run
cuz if I run that guy in that truck's
going to call the cops the cops would
love to know where I
am uh so you know I'm I'd put before I
came into the to the uh to the fork in
the road there I'd put my wash myself
put my clothes on so I'd be appear
normal and so I'm I'm standing sitting
on my horse there and I I suppressed a a
big urge to run I thought no no no I
can't run cuz he's going to report me
I'll just look
normal so he says
uh he said to me who are
you and I said my name's Colin
danguard and he says what are you doing
out here I says riding my
horse you should be in
school I and straight and straight away
I started stuttering again so I couldn't
talk
properly and but I didn't want to gallop
off so I just stayed there and he says
um you should be in
school shook my head and he said
well what do you want to be when you
grow up I said a writer I want to be a
writer he said do you
read and I said yeah so so got reach
back in my old saddle bag I'd built
myself a an old Australian stock saddle
from bits and parts I'd found took out a
copy of Jack
London Call of the Wild I showed him a
book he said oh Jack London he says I
read Jack
London ah so we got to talking about
Jack London and I relaxed a lot and I
was speaking a bit better because I was
relaxed and he says
he said okay he said in one week's time
I'm coming by here again he said I'm
going to leave a something for you under
that gum
tree I said okay and he to my great
relief he drove off I was well that's
what I call a close call CU he's not
going to call I felt very sure he wasn't
going to tell
anybody
so a whole week I
waited to one wondering what was going
to be under that gum tree for me what
this old what this old guy is going to
leave
me and I go back ride back 30 miles took
me all day to get back there again and
uh there was even another sugar bag from
mother which was
great um so there's some supplies there
and underneath the the gum tree was a
olivetti portable Royal
typewriter must have been made in the
20s it was an old old typewriter now I
knew about typewriters cuz before I got
thrown out of school they had a
typewriter and we could bang on the keys
this and it was a Catholic school and it
was just terrible terrible place I just
beat the hell out of us and um so I get
this type I wow he also had a stack of
papers there and three spare
ribbons I thought this is greatest thing
thing I've ever
seen a typewriter and it's mine wow so I
managed to get it on my horse Queenie
got the I got the stack of papers and I
got this typewriter and queenie's not
too happy about this so there a little
bit of pet and Rond Jam going on there
but I managed to stay on and don't drop
the typewriter if I was going off I
would was going to off going to land on
my back and hold the typewriter I
rehearsed the fall if I needed to but I
didn't have to fall so rode all day
balancing the typewriter I got back to
Patty's green and the Lagoon put the
typewriter on a rock and I just looked
at it and was mesmerized with this
typewriter thought wow that's the
greatest thing I've ever seen said yeah
so I thought in the morning I got up
early Sunrise Before Sunrise sat sat the
typewriter up on a Rock and uh started
banging away on the
keys I was so thrilled oh that's it I'm
going to start writing
stories I'm going to start writing
stories because I was I read a lot of
man magazines and Adam magazines and in
those days there were thousands of
magazines magazines for for boys who
were 10 boys who are 15 boys who were 20
Etc same with the girls there thousands
magazines everywhere so as a I'd read
quite a bit of Adam magazine and man
magazine and um they were the big ones
for the men and um they were high
adventure things and I thought oh I'm
going to write for them that's what I'm
going to do so I get the type get the
paper and the typewriter and start
tapping away queenie's right
there and I said Queenie listen to this
okay you
ready it was a dark night of course it
was a dark night every story has starts
with a dark and stormy night it wasn't
stormy though it was just Dark Bruce
looked out my man character Bruce Bruce
looked out across the Lagoon and what
did he
see he saw what other people would think
was a
dragonfly coming towards him just a
little speck on the mirror with the
Lagoon reflecting the the moon like a
mirror was just coming on moon starting
to come
up but Bruce knew it
was not a dragonfly because 20 ft behind
the dragonfly the water was being
disturbed
rhythmically Bruce knew it was a
crocodile and it was heading his
way I said to Queenie what do you think
of that Queenie is this going to be a
good story or what oh
so anyhow we got the story written and
it took me took me a week to write the
story about a thousand words and I
imitated how would be in man magazine
how they would write it and uh took it
back out because the old guy said he was
going to come in by in a week and that
was that that day would be a week and I
stayed there all day and sure enough a
Dusky comes by and I'm out there with my
horse St my horse
and uh I showed him this story I said
here's my first
story and he says he wrote something I
says
yeah I said you can he says can I read
it I says yeah I want you to read it
then I want you to copy post it to man
magazine this is their address here and
he says he read it and he says that's a
good
story I says yeah well I'm glad you like
it so first it off to man magazine then
I went back to the bush again so I
started writing again and
uh uh went and saw him next week and he
kept asking me if I had anything written
I said no I'm working on something so
about 4 weeks go by and I didn't go and
see him for three weeks but I went back
another time and sure enough he came
up and uh he said I got some news for
you he said uh man magazine then has
accepted your story I said you really
they did he said yeah they're going to
send you a check I said wow how much for
and he says for like
a1100 in those days would be enough
spending power today of about um $500 I
guess I said wow so I went got back to
the bush I said well I'm going to ride
another one I said uh
so uh I said we need some envelopes and
things so he said yeah I'll bring some
so I started so I wrote another story
and sure enough I that got published too
and I thought to myself wow this is this
is really good so I got an hour stack of
papers and I'm pounding out stories from
man magazine and then I thought well I
really got to got to get some money from
somewhere some cash now at this time in
Australian history in the 50s Australia
lost more men perhe of
population than any Allied country so
Australia in the 50s was full of old men
boys women and children that was it so
to solve this problem Australian
government wisely sent uh ships to Italy
Sicily Albania every country country in
Europe and if you if you a male and had
a heartbeat you got free passage to
Australia where somebody gave you Hunker
land and uh if you if you wanted to farm
or they got to got you a job at
someplace if you want to didn't want to
farm and uh they gave you essentially
what they what was a loan you had to pay
it back of course nobody ever did but
that was the government uh line on
it so uh the
uh I thought wow this
is this is great um now meanwhile the
the Australians up in the northern
cattle country where I was
[Music]
from um a lot of some of them were
Italians but there was established old
families there like mine we were there
in uh in the
1800s came early and there was wild
aboriginals all over the place in those
days so it was
um it
was pretty wild in this little tiny town
with the Italians fighting and they were
called new Australians and the new
Australians fighting the old Australians
and this little Dusty Main Street of
marba was just a blood bath every
Saturday morning people having
tremendous punch-ups oh my God and in
and and if people had punch-ups in those
days it was you didn't uh you didn't
stop the fight that wasn't the deal you
made a circle and you made sure that
nobody uh pulled a knife or or did any
underhand blows it had to be Queens to
be rules as they said so you had to had
to shape up and punch punch and and
defend and do all that stuff and you
could knock somebody down and uh so it
was it was just the wildest wildest town
but the the dver had come from the north
with their cattle and they would uh sell
their cattle at this cattle yard in
mariba let the horses go loose and
they'd come into town fight the Italians
for a whole week and it' Be Blood and
Guts in the streets of mariva and then
uh then they go back in the blitz truck
America during its occupation of
Australia not its occupation while they
were there to defend us from the
Japanese they all had these Blitz trucks
which are built by Ford you thousands
and thousands of Blitz trucks so uh when
the when the Americans left they were
supposed to destroy all these Blitz
trucks but they didn't instead they left
keys in them so anybody you could find a
blitz truck with a key in it you owned
it so they would these DS had put their
all their stuff in the blitz trucks and
go back again and repeat the whole
exercise five months later and bring the
cattle in so I'm out in the bush now and
I'm thinking God there's a lot of
brumbies out here we call them brumbies
but they weren't really brumbies
brumbies is wild horses they weren't
really wild at all they're abandoned
stock horses they all had white marks on
their backs from wear Saddles
ill-fitting Saddles had taken their hide
off during these long driving trips that
went for 3 months four months 5 months
and um so what's I'm going to do I'm
going to round up these round up some of
these r
and see if I can sell them so I went out
to a tobacco
farm uh a newly settled tobacco farm on
the rim of the Outback there and uh
wasn't too far a ride from Patty's
green and um made myself known to the
Italian guy who owned he didn't speak
any English and I didn't speak any
Italian but I made it clear that I
wanted to work for him and he said yeah
fine so I'm hauling tobacco out of the
field and tobacco is really sticky
horrible nasty stuff put under your arm
carried out and take it to the shed
where people strung it to Long poles and
put it in a in a barn in a tin barn
under which their fire burned so they
dry out the
tobacco and um they're paying me by what
I could carry out of the field so I got
this great idea so I thought well I'll
make two
shaves uh nail some planks across it uh
put a tie around queeny's neck put a
rope around it around the belly and I'll
be able to haul this tobacco out of the
field and oh we have a lot of tobacco
because I want have to carry it out of
the field so the Italian guy saw this
and he thought this was the greatest
thing he'd ever seen he wants to buy my
horse I said nah I'll bring you a horse
bring you bring your horse and he says
yeah so I go back to the Patty's green
where all these brumbies are running
around and uh I followed the railway
line to the first there was an old
little Railway line nearby where it had
a rail motor that went out a little bit
in the bush but at the end of this where
the motor turned around there was an
ouse there so I checked the ouse and
it's got big rolls of toilet paper
government rolls big things about 2 ft
across you know you could do what you do
with toilet paper or you could you know
use it for sand would be do the same job
so I thought this is great so I grab
steel two of those big rolls take them
back to Patty's green and tied them to
trees and made a big V like that and
there was an old cattle yard there left
a big old log yard was rotten but it was
enough enough Timber still on it to make
it um
blockable and then with Queenie I got on
the downside this and I got a stock whip
I'm good with whips
so chase the mob here chase the mob
there and funnel them towards this big
funnel of paper up this yard boom there
it
is wow there's 35 30 head of horses
there that's really wonderful so lock
lock them up there bring the logs in
they can't get
out and I thought this is this is really
wonderful uh so I thought well this is
going to be good I'll uh I'll wait they
weaken up a bit so I left in there for 3
days with no water no food nothing as
soon when the head started to drop I
thought that's it put a rope around six
of them took them out to the tobacco
farm and uh said to the tobacco said to
the guy says here one
horse you can buy this horse and so he
was very thrilled about buying this
horse and he paid me uh we negotiated a
fee and it turned out to be like five 5B
5 sterling pounds per horse and um and
these horses were half dead from having
no food and no water so I said look they
they're very very calm look there's no
problem look here horses are half dead
and um he said yeah okay so gives me the
money and I got the hell out of that
farm because as soon as you got all of
those horses they'll be they'll be tone
all that be just go berserk because
you'd have to train them to pull the
logs and things and pull the Dr so then
i' had uh I had all this money then said
well wow so I hang hang around I went
back to the bush and and it was good
then I had thought well I'm going to go
down and see my Aunt Mary cuz she had
sent messages back to me and said she
had been reading my stories in man
magazine and Aunt Mary was my dad's
sister and uh she was very encouraging
when I went down to cans and said saw
her and she said you know she said said
you ride like Hemingway and I said
really I'm glad you think so she said
yeah but you should do something with
your talent you're just writing for man
magazines she said uh if you want to
really write for and get a lot of money
you got to write for the woman's
magazines you got to write romance I
thought well wow romance yeah okay so I
go back to the bush thinking how am I
going to write romance well didn't seem
to be too difficult because uh I was
certainly a horn dog out there for sure
had nothing to jump on so you know it
was easy to imagine romance romance to
me was cuddling a woman and having a
good time that was good so I went with
that for a while and uh wrote a couple
of romance stories and they got
published too and um and I went back to
see Aunt Mary again and she says you
know she saidou got to do something with
your talent she says you're wasting your
time and now now I'm about 16 years old
and uh and she says R Sutton is the
editor of the can's posts and he lives
just across the street from
me I've arranged an interview you go and
see red Sutton and apply for a job as a
gadet reporter and I said yeah okay good
idea and I'm hbling around I got shoes
on because out in the bush I didn't wear
shoes and my feet had spayed out and I
had to peel had to trim the back of my
feet with
a pocket knife that I got all of and um
otherwise they'd spay out and split to
split to your flesh and cause you all
kind of problems so I'm hobbling around
I go and see red Sutton and he says to
me he says well he says
um yeah he said I've read some stuff and
your Aunt Mary that Aunt Mary gave me
and she said he says you write very well
he says you got a job he says give me
your high school certificate and you
hired so I looked him High School
certificate he says yes I go oh okay
High School certificate okay he said you
don't have any problem with that do you
he says how old are you I said well I'm
18 I wasn't I was 16 he said well I said
well we had a big fire at the cattle
property and lost all the papers he says
yeah well the education department will
give you a copy of your high school
certificate because without it you can't
get hired I can't hire you it's illegal
I said okay all right well I'll I'll
solve that problem so I waited till he
left that night and when he left
I I went to the sub editor the night guy
and I said uh I say good my name's Colin
dangard I'm the new night
reporter he
said you been hired I said yeah Mr sat
and hired me this afternoon he didn't
tell me that I said well he's probably
an H what do you want me to do so he
said he says well I don't know I don't
know I didn't know I said well I don't
know just anything what do you got in
mind and he said he says there some
crazy guy out at Red Fern attacked his
neighbor with an axe he said uh the cops
are investigating it nobody got killed
but it's one of those ax assault stories
you know I said oh yeah okay so I go I
go to the cop shop and uh talk to and
talk at length with the police and
they're telling me everything I need to
know and there's Ratt rattling off
everything so I thought that's good so I
go back to The Newsroom there's nobody
there except me so I type this story out
until about 6:00 or 7 in the morning I
stay there and I wrote this like I was
writing for man magazine I wrote but it
was quote from the cop quote from the
neighbor quote from this quote from that
you know quote quote quote quote little
bit of
description I thought this is this is
easy so I slipped it under red s 's
door and waited for him to come to
work and he charged down the hallway
with his briefcase and slammed his
office
door 3 minutes later and I'd slipped my
my story under the door under his under
his door of his office 3 minutes later
the secretary comes in and says Colin Mr
satton wants to see you and he is not
happy or warn you I said okay so I go to
see red
Sutton and he says' don't sit down cuz
this is not going to take
long he said right now I have a dilemma
I have to figure out how to fire you but
I don't know how to legally do that
because I haven't even hired you he says
you've masqueraded yourself as a
reporter for the can's
post and you've
downgraded our standing enormously
by pretending to be somebody you are
not so well I don't know I said I just
wrote the story as I saw it and he says
well get out of here and I'll decide
what I'm going to do so I left him
stayed there most of the day and didn't
see him again but the addition came
out next morning late that night for the
Morning Edition and uh there it was my
story big story everything every golden
word as they said it was all
there I'm done I'm done so the um the
secretary secretary comes out and says
your paycheck will be ready Friday
morning
10:00 so I leave then I was hired and it
was the start of an incredible
journalistic career that I had I stayed
there for couple of years and then I
went to
looked on the map of Australia and I saw
the nearest country was New Zealand I
thought well I'm going to New Zealand
because it's not too far away start with
there so I go to New Zealand and I get
hired by the uh roru post they hired me
as a lake Tapo
correspondent Lake Tapo is a little
trout fishing lake in the middle of the
north island and um it was great I
thought this is this is really good I
stayed at um
the spa hotel in
TBO I had a 650 BSA bike that IID
brought from Australia brought with me
from Australia board over on our ship
from Australia and uh at the spa hotel I
became good friends with uh the
proprietor was name was Jim
Bernie and he was very good friends with
uh Keith Holo who would become new Zeal
the prime minister of New Zealand so I
became very very friendly with sir
Keith and uh we got chatting every every
morning at breakfast and whenever he was
there and Jim Bernie was singing my
praise about what I was writing and I'm
a now very well established feature
writer for the rotary post and and
um um Holio says to me one day he says
what are you going to do now and he says
you're pretty well established here he
says
uh you're going to move on I says yeah I
said uh want to go up to Pacific
someplace and uh he said oh yeah he said
he said here so he wrote me a personal
letter of
reference signed by the prime minister
of New Zealand I thought wow this is
something so I go up to New Zealand and
uh I go up to uh
Fiji and uh walk into the into the Fiji
Times and uh took myself into a job
there as usual didn't seem to be
difficult to do my reputation had
preceded me
somewhat and uh so I started a great
time in Fiji once again as a feature
writer some writing great stuff for the
Fiji Times and I'm sending off
dispatches to London and Australia and
I'm the became uh the news of the world
correspondent in
Fiji and uh same in Sydney and this is
going really good I'm thinking this is
this is great I says you can this is
just like printing your own money and
I'd become friends with uh these New
Zealand
ammen who flew Sunderland out of uh out
of
Fiji and uh one of the things we we'd
like to do was I had a nice apartment
overlooking the Big Bay there so every
Friday we'd all get together and up at
my place all us guys and we endless
drinking and couple of kegs of beer and
motus op randos we'd hop in bunch of
cars and go down and and go trolling for
uh newb nyph fets under palm trees and
things any any girls that were young and
available we just grab them grab them
throw them in the car take them up to
our apartment uh and be an ory going
like crazy within about within no time
at all and we're having bring such a
good time with this it was just so much
fun the girls were having a good time
they're giggling and cackling and
carrying on and then
um one day I got uh part of my job in
Fiji was to go and see the police chief
every morning and he was a British guy
and British outfits on a Prest
outfit a great heir of self-importance
about him and he would tell me what I
should write and shouldn't write and he
said uh we' be having tea and scon at
10:30 in the morning and he there was
only me and him and he says yeah he says
we came we become quite funny he says
yeah col he says I got to tell you a
story he says of course you can't print
this but he says uh it's just a funny
story he say out at out of van out in
the island of van he said on a beach out
there we had to go out
and uh quell a
disturbance all the boxes gone crazy
because there was some some girl from
Australia was running naked up and down
on the beach wearing nothing but a Bowie
and a and a and a uh Bowie and that's
all she was wearing a Bowie knife
nothing else she's running up and down
the beach and of course all the Bucks
all the young Fijian guys were
mesmerized with it and they started
carrying around on a sedan chair she
became a sex godess can you believe that
he's told me he said of course you can't
pray any of this he says it's just I
think it's very funny I say yeah you
know that's a power of women and they
take off their clothes and guys fall
over everywhere says these are warriors
and they fall over that's ridiculous and
I go back to the pg times I'm sitting
there I said
well yeah that's a hell of a story News
of the World had love this
story let me see how would it
Go shapely beautiful naked Australian
blonde running on the
beach
mesmerizing powerful Fiji
bucks much to the anger of their
wives no couldn't write that here I
could could write it in London yes so
bang it out bang it out sent it to news
of the world like it's going on another
planet I didn't even think far enough
well news of the world is just over
there London is not too far
away Fiji after all is a British crowned
colony of course I didn't think that far
I just s of making a Big Splash in
London with this hot hot
story and um so uh I said well yeah the
police chief did tell me it was in
secret that he was telling me this
but uh I'm a reporter I'm supposed to
supposed to say things that other people
don't want me to write especially if
they people in positions of power I
should be standing with the side of the
people I'm telling myself all this it
sounded all very good so anyhow the
story comes out and uh comes out in news
the world in London and it's a big
splash oh my God they went crazy for
this story and that was that weekend
we're having a one a
usual sare with all all these British
these New Zealand am from aala Bay and
we got all the babes there and there uh
there's there's uh
um half cloud and no clad young girls
running around the apartment and they're
all drunk and spring out and we're
dancing and carrying on and there's lots
of action on couches and every other
place and I look out the window into my
horror there's a line of
police vehicles out there I said what
are they
doing I wonder what they're doing here
and they're running up the steps towards
my place I'm thinking oh my God they're
coming here they're coming here look out
look across the room and here
are uh you know people bent over couches
and rumbling rumbling here and rumbling
there and I thought wow this doesn't
look good and so I try to get
these these women out to the back door
the apartments was built into a bank so
you back door was another flat area so I
get them all get as many of them I could
out of there as I hear the door the
police breaking down down the front door
and U then I there's some there's some
cage wire there so I pull it up pull up
and get all these chicks in there and to
my horror I'm in the middle of a chicken
ceop and chickens go berserk I mean
there's flying chickens everywhere and
the women are screaming and carrying on
hav't got no clothes on there's about 15
young girls there and and I look up and
there's a flashlight coming down and the
end of the flashlight I see a double
barrel shotgun and I said uh excuse me
yeah don't worry I can explain
everything and then very British accent
he says U oh my dear I don't think you
can explain anything here to me but he
said you'll be explaining it to the
police chief okay don't
move so anyhow I end up in
jail and uh next
morning uh I'm in the
dock strange to be in the dock do where
I'd reported on reported on many other
misgivings of other people who had
transgressed the law from the court
where as a reporter and the the
magistrate looks at me and he's shocked
to see me there and the prosecutor said
uh he wants to talk to you so I go up
and talk to the magistrate and he says
colon he says you are in a lot of
trouble off the record I have to tell
you he says these are underage
girls he said you can go away for a very
long time with this they're all
drunk you he said um it's he said I
suggest you plead
guilty and the charge is supplying
liquor to
natives I said okay so we get go back to
the dock and they read to charge out and
how do I plead I pr guilty for supplying
Li to Native so I get deported within 24
hours from f
G so I arrive then I fly to Sydney
and then I get hired because uh uh I
didn't get hired right away but I went
to the pub uh where all of the
journalists hang out the bar and I said
well I'll apply for a job
here on the Sydney Sun or the miror of
one of those papers and uh it was it was
great so
that's I did know that they had run my
big story from Fiji they picked it up
from News of the World in London re
reprinted it and um but the editor
wasn't too sure about me because uh he
said I don't know he says you you seem a
bit
controversial he said I don't know if we
need some controversial guy she''s been
deported that doesn't sound good I said
yeah but it was just a stupid thing
drunken party you know what I mean yeah
well he says I don't know about that so
um so uh I heard that they were going to
have a beer drinking
competition the day the day after that
it was a Thursday I thought there was a
big dream being competition on
Friday at the at the hotel where all the
journalist hung out I said hm I told
myself that's it I can I can drink all
these people under the table no trouble
at all so I went into training I got 48
hours to train up for the beer drinking
competition so I denied myself uh just
took a little bit of sip of water sip of
this sip of that you know made myself uh
took a lot of vitamins I could find and
did push-ups and do all those things
that you got to do when you're going
into a beer drinking competition right
so I were at the all I I came I
represented not a newspaper but an
independent
an associate of the sun I call myself an
independent associate of the sun and the
editor of the sun was there and he says
uh he says you're not really on staff at
the sun he says how can you say that I
said well I said associate okay okay
well I said I'm in the competition
anyhow I said and everybody else is
going to
lose oh yeah it's Jimmy madens over
there jimm Madden has never lost this
ever he works for the
mirror 10 years you can't drink him
under the table I says no problem at all
I said I'm probably the best Beer
Drinker in the world he says really
that's ridiculous that's totally
ridiculous anyhow the beer drinking
competition starts and there was boat
racing rules boat racing rules was
Schooner you drank from Schooners and
skooner is a 16 o glass and boat racing
rules means you all the contestants
stand in a circle and you dra you drain
your glass and if you drain your glass
everybody's got drain their glass so you
can you can have you can speed it up and
knock out the knock out the competition
very quickly so I'm dehydrated by the
time I get there I'm highly trained up
for this beer dring competition so I I
knock over five Schooners in a
row without
without even sweating on eyelid well
that cut the field down by
2/3 and I look over and there's the
legendary Jimmy Madden and he's looking
at me he knows I'm the competition and
in these rules you know you uh if you
throw if you throw up you got tossed out
you're lost you had to walk a straight
line you had to be able to read the
newspaper you accompanied if you wanted
to take a pee you had to be accompanied
by a second to make sure that you didn't
just up and come back you had to you had
to hold your liquor as I said
well so it went on and on and we got up
to 16 Schooners Jimmy Madden and I
Schooner 17 there's only Madden and I
left and I and I and I'm I'm feeling it
and I know Jimmy Madden's feeling it too
because he's feeling a bit
wobbly and I said seconds Jimmy Madden
needs to take a a walking test
oh okay I said so they walked in me
Madden and he they have a vote on it
there the the pub is crowded with people
there's probably 200 Spectators easily
cars are honking outside and parking
triple parked on the street and this is
the biggest it's the biggest thing
that's happened in a long long time at
this hotel and uh so anyhow we got down
to Glass H Jimmy Madden and
I scoon of 17
I said Jimmy you're quite a drinker but
you're not good
enough put
down he say I can't do that put his
hands up so I won the beer drinking
competition three days later I got on
the wrong train went out I woke up
there's trees going past I thought God
where the hell am I I'm supposed to be
at Glee across the harbor I have an
apartment there I'm looking out the
windows trains trees G by
oh I pull a cord train comes to a stop
conductor comes up and he says did you
pull that
cord I said yeah I said why'd you do
that I said I'm dying I think I'm going
to die he says well you're not dying on
my train get off it so kicks me off the
goddamn train just kicks me off and I'm
like dehydrated and I feel shocking I
feel terrible and um train goes
by and then there's
nothing just trees Wilderness a train
track and I'm sitting there thinking God
I'm so feel so bad and then I look up
and there's one of those PP trolleys
come along that get out in the track and
stop the
guys so they're really what are you
doing
here my whole life has been people
asking me what am I doing here so I said
well it's a long story but I said I got
to get back to Sydney
Sydney that's 150 mi from here I said
yeah I don't know how I got here but I'm
in the wrong place and I'm dying do you
have any
water you look drunk to me says one of
them so they says yeah jump on here so
they they um PMP trollied me out out of
there for about 2 hours and I got off
that finally got back to my place 3 days
later and I'm
dying so I go back to the newspaper I'm
thinking this is it you know and Len Coy
was the editor KY calls me and he says
hey you come here and KY was as rough as
guts uh he used to he used to just uh we
had some girl reporters and they' burst
into tears every time they saw him cuz
he says if you don't show me your tits
you don't do anything here you don't get
any pay unless you show me your tits
okay anything wrong with that what you
look at your tits every day I can look
at them too and she's going on like this
this is what this is what it was and I
thought well he's going to he's going to
kick me out of here and that'll be end
that he says he's eating a meat pie and
he's stuffing it in his mouth God he was
rough that guy and he's scratching his
balls and looking at me and he says you
know he says I was going to fire your
ass he says you're a bit of a wreck if
you ask me he says but you won the beer
drinking competition we've never won it
you drank Madden under the table I said
yeah well you know I'm just dying I'm
halfway dying and he says see that
window over there he says that desk over
there he that's where you are and he
says your job is going to be police
rounds a car will pick you up at 4 4:30
in the morning from wherever you live
and um you'll go to the police club and
you're going to buy every all the cops
in their drinks you're going to have
unlimited expense account because he
says nothing talks better than a drunk
cop okay
but you're a beer drinking Champion so
you won't get drunk they're all amateurs
you got it you got you got my drift here
I said yeah okay so that was my job so
I'm PR oh now the police
roundsman okay I'm um next after Sydney
I went to uh went up got on a boat
called the Tuan I was supposed to go to
Vancouver where I got a job in the
Vancouver
Sun uh by mail I got off in the boat in
Hong Kong met an old friend of mine
Alfred Lee and Steve D leevy couple of
friends from Sydney got roaring
drunk uh Monday realized the boat had
sailed off without me and with all my
luggage so I ended up getting a job in
Hong Kong and became editor of the Hong
Kong star after this is when the Vietnam
War was on so Hong Kong was wide open it
was Sin City multiplied by 10,000 it was
unbelievable it was just had the best
time I got to speak I got to speak
canones somewhat Pillow Talk mostly but
that's all you needed and um then round
went to Europe and all through Europe
and became uh started collecting
newspapers that I could correspond with
then I went to U then I went to South
Africa and got to talk my way on a job
at the uh Johannesburg Sunday times
again to be a feature writer and that
was fantastic had a very good time there
and um uh went up and covered some stuff
in Zambia where they started shooting
white people so I thought ah this is not
good South Africa's G gone to Hell in a
hand basket so I decided I want to get
out of South Africa U because I'd been
in communist China and uh the the U the
secret police in South Africa was in
aath at the time they didn't like the
idea that that i' that I'd been in China
they thought I was a communist spy it's
just me a communist spy I'm just a
stupid working stiff journalist you know
so anyhow I uh I'm trying to figure out
how I can get out of Jo Jo where am we
going to go next and then I get a call
from my friend Dennis
budge uh we had been deported from
Tahiti
together after Fiji I did a quick sent
in Tahiti and got deported from there
again and um so uh Dennis calls me up
and he says colon he says
uh where are you I said I'm in jaberg I
says where are you he says I'm in Cape
Town he says i' I said what are you
doing there he said I've just sailed a
little boat 34t catch across in across
the Indian and he says I'm going to go
to America I said that's funny that's
exactly where I want to go I said I'm 27
years old the vi they can't draft me for
Vietnam so I'm out of here so I go down
and join Dennis and and as walking down
the dock in Cape Town uh I'm with my
first wife Kay who was a real prissy
sort of thing and I was never uh never
up to her standard of what she thought a
husband should be
well I can't blame her for that either I
you know I did tell her I'd screw
everything that moved so I wasn't lying
about that U so we're walking down and
she says and at the end of the pier uh
there was a magnificent yacht there
owned by a guy called Franson who is a
multi zillionaire from from Canada and
she says oh look at that she says I can
see myself in the poop deck there having
my T scans would't that be nice G maybe
oh and you finally done something I says
I'm sorry that's not the boat that's not
that's not the yacht so we walk takes us
about 5 minutes to walk the full length
of the of fransen's yacht and down there
look down there there's Dennis's boat
34t catch it looked like a
whole cheap of garbage with a sail on it
Dennis looks like he says hey call how
you doing mate he says come on down he
says tell tell you lady there to get
those high heels off cuz you can't walk
in high heels in this boat and you'll
trip yourself in that that rope ladder
so she takes those so we get down the
boat and K looks at me and says we are
not sailing this anywhere she says I'm
out here I said I don't think so tell
any we we talk her into saying and
Dennis says well one thing says I got a
he I'm glad you've come he says I know
you're handy with your hands he says we
have to this boat keeps trying to sink
he says it's takes in water I said says
well that's a bad thing isn't it I said
we're going to go to America right and
he says yeah and I says but you slip the
boat he says now he says I have to learn
how to navigate he said I missed Africa
by 1,000 miles so I can't do that again
cuz we're gone that way it's 6,800 mil
to reach Barbados so got to get that
under control he says yeah fine okay we
slip the boat I'll I'll do the cing I'll
C the boat I'll learn how to do it you
learn how to navigate so he took off his
sex and and his navigation book and
manag to find figure out how to use his
sexon and U I'm trying to plug up this
boat and there old guys hanging around
the dock docks are always full of old
guys this old guy comes on me he says
what are you doing with this boat I says
well we're going to sail it to America
he says you're not going to get out of
the harbor in this thing he says it's
it's water logged I says what does that
mean he looked at me like a stupid he
says you've never said anything at all
have you I says no but I'll learn so he
pulled out app pliers from his tool box
and he and his tool pouch and he poked
the side of it and water spurred it out
he said see that it's water loged you're
going to sink I said well we'll plug up
all the holes and and uh and dry it out
and we'll be fine and he says even if
you managed to seal this boat he
said you're going to you're going to die
at the do drum
I says what's that the doldrums you
don't know what the doldrums are where
the South Atlantic meets the North
Atlantic there's nothing for one mile or
15 miles no wind no nothing underneath
the doldrums there's 10,000 sailing
ships you don't have a motor on this
piece of garbage how you going to get
across the doldrums you're going to
die well he was almost right about that
one for sure but anyhow we sailed out
and it was a long arduous Journey the
women hated each other there's there's a
there's a saying that you should never
put a never put women on a on a Sailing
Boat it's quite true women on sailing
boats try to kill each other so these
women were fighting all the time and but
we did manage to sail 6,000 800 mil with
no
motor radar no radar are nothing if you
fell off that boat you were dead
couldn't turn the boat
around uh so you'd just die sharks
everywhere and Dennis wonderful Dennis
he didn't believe in God so he'd take
off all his clothes and beat his chest
and stand up on the heliad and say come
on God if you're there sink me you son
of a you're not there that's why
you can't sink
me it's skone in the middle of the night
you know so anyhow got to America and
[Music]
um got to went got to got to Miami and
uh walked into the Miami Herald when the
when the editor's secretary was got took
a break or something like dashed in and
Larry Jinx was the editor and I shook
hands with leaned over his desk and said
I'm Colin danguard I'm from Australia he
says well if you're looking for a job
there's no jobs here I said well that's
okay I said I I got arrest I've just
sailed a 34t catch from from from uh
from South Africa he said you did turned
out he was a biscane bay yti so he was
absolutely thrilled with my stories so
then I got hired and became a feature
writer again and had a wonderful time
they won lots of awards but the Miami
Herald writing feature stories for them
then I get a call from rert Murdoch I'm
now separated myself from the Miami
Herald I kept him as a client but I had
was now syndicating to 130 Publications
each month in 30 different
countries then rert Murdock calls me and
he says colon he says we're coming to
America we're going to start the
national star we want you to be the
Hollywood editor for us and I said uh
rert I'm sorry I'm very well Ascot right
now I got my old deal going everything's
can't find he says you're going to get a
call from Sir Larry
Lamb I said okay so Larry Lamb calls me
up and he says so he says you're going
to Hollywood you're going to be The
Hollywood Reporter for the national star
the national you're going to be the
Hollywood editor for the national star I
says I don't think so I said I'm just
bought a house in bookery to I got
horses at the polo club I'm making so
much money I don't know what to do with
it I'm syndicating in 30 countries and
he says well how much money did he make
and I I thought of what I made and I
doubled it and he says oh we can match
that easy what else you got I says well
I'm syndicating to 30 countries and he
says well he I don't see a problem with
that as long as we have the stories
first in the National side don't give a
damn and I said oh okay and I said well
I got these horses at the Palm Beach
Polo Club oh they got those trucks with
little horse carriages and they take
them to America take them to Los Angeles
for you no problem at all what else you
got I said well I just bought a new
house in Boer to he say no problem they
got lots of houses in in La we'll buy
house there wherever you want to buy
we'll just put you so I said yeah okay
okay okay so I could keep my syndication
they were paying me a lot of money so it
was the beginning of a huge huge
wonderful time as a as a very highly
paid syndicated self- syndicated
columnist I was the only self-
syndicated person in America which I
could never figure out why other
individuals didn't start their own
syndicates why not so but could never
figure that anyhow so I'm in I'm in
Hollywood having a great time and R's
paying me a lot of money and my
syndicate's making me a lot of money and
I get a television show and I'm working
on on I'm on that show it's called uh um
Colin danguard uh just Colin dard show
and uh on view with Colin dard was cool
so I got a house on the beach in Malibu
and I get divorce which is a smart thing
to do and and I filled my house with
beautiful women and have a sex secretary
who did nothing else to keep track of my
wom I had 15 14 girlfriends at once and
I ran on the beach and kept my stamina
up so I could satisfy all these girls
and I'm making so much money I just
didn't know what to do with it I'm
having such a good time and uh so uh I'm
on a plane going from zerich to London
one day I'm bird dog and Elizabeth
Taylor as I always did and she hated
hated my guts and she looks across in
first class and I'm sitting there oh she
just about had a foot so she tore a
strip off me and she says you know she
says all you do in your life is write
nasty stuff about people half it's not
even true I don't know if it I said well
is I got a tape recorder it's course it
is she said well get rid of that tape
recorder right now so okay put there are
so she said I want to tell you a couple
of things she says you're quite a nice
guy really he says she said but you
spend your life writing nasty stuff
about people and making money out of out
of turning people's lives into horror
stories and what have you done with your
life and I had to think for a while I
must say I came up short I said well I
write stories she said you write stories
about people who've done something what
have you done I thought
well well one of the most syndicated
people in the world Rex Reed may have
bigger readers me but I don't think
so she she say you wasting your life so
I go back to Malibu go back to my house
on the
beach um yeah I'm making all this money
I'm thinking you know she's right
Elizabeth Taylor's right what have I
done with my life I haven't done
anything sure I report on people yeah
well anybody could do that I get a tape
recorder that does that I just put it
together so I said that's it I'm going
to quit the whole thing call up rer quit
the star he didn't care he he was on his
way everything was fine call up my
editors no I'm not doing this I'm not
doing that anymore so I feel greatly
relieved now and uh I got 13 girlfriends
and uh you know a secretary did nothing
else to keep track of my girlfriends and
and uh you know it was it was a big
challenge but anyhow so uh and Renee who
was in charge of organizing my
girlfriend she said you know you're
going to lose all this
you're just walking away from her I says
yeah ain't that great and I said yeah I
don't need it I'm going to go out and do
something different she said what is it
I said I have no idea now isn't that
exciting I have no
idea and she calls my accountant my
accountant calls me and says Colin this
is a very stupid idea whatever it is you
got he says you've been drinking I said
no I hav hav had drink for a while I
said no I said I'm matter you
and he says well you're going to get
broke and sure enough I said well if I
do I do but I'm going to find out if I
can do something else besides this I
said an orangutan could do this I said I
want to do something exciting was it
Elizabeth Taylor they got you to quit
yeah Elizabeth Taylor so I'm thinking of
what she's
saying and so so I so okay that's it
then I get a call from the studio and
they
said making a movie in Australia would
you like to go and I says yeah if it's
Australia I'll go and for me to a movie
company to get me on a set was a big
coup CU they Hollywood hadn't yet got
the idea I was abandoning it and uh but
I was and I said what's the movie about
well it's
about it's an adaptation from a poem I
said that sounds really
exciting I didn't care about it cuz I'm
going to go to Australia see my family
and see my brothers and sisters this
stupid Studios is going to pay pay for
the money and I'll just make an
appearance on the set and write a story
and I'll be okay just make it whole for
them and I go on the set the movie is a
man from snow
River and I'm looking at it I thought
this is the dumbest movie I ever saw
it's adapt an adaptation from a a poem
by banjo Patterson was very familiar
with the poem The Man from snow River
said how can you make a movie about that
but anyhow then I saw the director comes
he says col he says I want you to look
at our dailies look at this and I see a
closeup of an Australian stock seller I
said why did you shoot that he says
we're going to show how Australians
really ride he says you know they ride
horses like the cacs used to hell bent I
said tell me about it I'm from there
that's what I did ride hellbent you know
that's what we did rode horses into the
ground got off them if they didn't get
up slit their throats and got another
one there's plenty out there it was very
brutal brutal on people brutal on horses
it was the most brutal thing I ever
experienced as a as a Horseman so it's
it uh uh so um I thought to myself wait
a minute American are riding this stupid
western saddle which nobody can ride
they could ride English saddles which
are very twe and very nice and put on
your nice thing and you you look good
jumping over jumps and but they're no
good for riding out in a bush Rough
Country Australians have the Saddles
that got knee pads on them we call
poliy I said that's it I'm going to take
that saddle America and sell it and I'm
going to ride the man from snow River I
think it's going to be a hit movie and I
did got all my money together got a
shipment of saddles from Australia from
s Hill and Sons and uh did a big ad
campaign on borrowed money from my
girlfriends and said Ride Like the man
from snow River and I went from being
dead broke to almost losing the house to
selling
$100,000 worth of saddles a
month half it was mine and we are
talking 35 years ago
that was a huge sum of money so I'm
wealthy again I said
wellow what a great country America is I
just can't get over this country you can
fall on your ass and you can get up and
do it again wow huh it's a really good
thing so any rode that for a long time
and I thank Elizabeth Taylor for that if
it wasn't her pushing telling me to get
get my head screwed on and go and do
something original
and I was the first guide to bring a new
saddle to
America in almost 300 years nobody did
that and it was a simple old Australian
stock saddle that I had ridden as a
boy come full circle made a fortune with
it and
uh started whole companies in India
producing them because Australia
couldn't produce the numbers I needed I
was getting shipments of saddles to my I
moved out of my house down the beach in
Malibu got a much bigger property up in
Kanan Doom Road where I now and there's
a parking lot there that's almost it's
almost an acre parking lot I had a
shipment come in that was so heavy that
when we stack the Saddles nose to nose
in this parking lot and fill the entire
parking
lot so you know it was it was a great
ride and fantastic and and that's what
you're still doing today that's what I'm
still doing that's my main business but
my main business now I'm starting to
write again I like to write books as I
I've got a got a novel out there called
talking with
horses um the horse for me has always
been a very special animal because
without the horse I'd be nobody without
the horse I wouldn't be able to speak
without the horse I wouldn't have a
business without the horse I wouldn't be
I wouldn't be a rider the horse is the
key to everything in my
life do you have any regrets in your
life no not at
all
uh yeah the first wife I could have done
without
her sailing across the boat my friend
Dennis sailing from Africa my friend
Dennis decided that these two women were
a pain in the ass and he called me into
his Chambers as he called him his
Chambers where four of us on this leaky
wooden wooden boat and he says the
captain needs to speak with you
and I says really so we're all formal he
reaches behind himself and he pulls out
a book a maritime law says punches here
says
here I'm the captain of the ship I have
to make a decision here to
protect the life of the vessel and those
aboard so I'm have to make a decision
here these two women are endangering the
ship with their
behaviors one of them picked up a knife
the other day we could have a death on
board he said so he says I have to ask
you a question how much do you love your
wife said well you know it's off and on
is it you know what I mean I said how
much do you love your wife and he says
well she's a sailor your wife's not one
of these one of these one of these has
to go
overboard I us I don't think so I said
they'll lock us up I said we leave South
Africa with four people aboard and we
get to BOS our first
landfall and we have three people aboard
what are we going to say happened to the
fourth he said we could say you got
swept overboard this we have no radio no
way to contact anybody and it was true
we had no radio we had nothing if we
sunk in that boat to be end of everybody
they would never know where we were you
and uh so I didn't want to do that but
anyhow so yeah I do have some regret so
we show but if you had to live your life
all over again are there things you wish
you had
done uh no as far as a big picture no I
always want to be a writer and if I say
so myself that's what I'm good at and
you were mingling with a lot of
Hollywood celebrities and stuff yes I
had a I was very very successful at that
and I had a talk show Robin Le took it
over he got backed by some big money and
it became Lifestyles of the Rich and
Famous and at that time I was getting
out of it I was getting out of Hollywood
I want to do something else what do you
think of the Hollywood scene that you
were um in bunch of Pretenders a bunch
of opportunities but I always looked at
um celebrities as being stalks of corn
wavering in the field to be harvested by
me
that was it I
felt they had a story to tell and I was
a guy to tell it on my
terms and it' be shooting straight from
the hip and if they were smart they
would understand that any publicity is
good publicity yes if they were smart
but a lot of them are not too smart but
I did get sued a lot spanks and arra
sued me for 30 million back when 30
million was 100 million u m Farah sued
me you know I got sued a lot
but uh uh rert was always first on the
ticket on the docket and I'd be the
second one but interestingly ruer was
such an amazing person to work for he
never mentioned it to me I get a saw a
lawsuit from $20 million for Frank
Sinatra he would I just get a call from
his attorney and said Colin we have to
talk about
this Frank shatra says you made up that
entire story I says well he's full of
crap I said I have a tape recording of
the interview there's a picture of me
holding a tape recorder while I'm with
Sinatra how can he deny that he says
really I says yeah so I went to court
and it got tossed out so the only person
who was successful at suing me was MIA
Farah who uh the story was she hated
kissing Robert
Redford and uh somebody called me from
from Rupert's office and said uh
rert doesn't think this story is true
and I says tell Rupert I have it on very
reliable
sources she comes back to me says
rubbert
says there wouldn't be a woman alive it
didn't want to kiss Robert
Redford and I says well I got on good so
I lost that I lost that round but
interestingly R didn't so MIA did not
she she denied yes she denied it and she
got paid out it cost uh cost news
limited uh million dollars or something
so you you said that Mia Farah Mia phoh
hated kissing Robert Redford hated
kissing Robert Redford yeah and I
believed a Stringer I believe I didn't
have the information firsthand I trusted
a Stringer who been working for me for
several years or for two or three years
anyway so that was wasn't right but
rubert picked it up right away
he's a t col I don't believe that if he
wants to go with it he can go with
it and uh so I believe the
Stringer happens do it you know you
can't be wrong you can't be right on
everything you have no children what no
CH no children yeah I have a I have one
son who uh um and his mother was uh she
was she became a top executive at Amazon
and made a ton of money I trained her up
to be a public relations person because
that was my business and uh because of
that training she got a job at Amazon
when that was starting and they didn't
have much to pay her in those days so
they gave her a whole lot of stock so
guess what she was worth many millions
uh and my son she took the took my son
basically and said your dad's a a a
chronic crazy person he's out of his
Loop he's just
nuts you want don't want anything to do
with him so Christian the son he he sort
of sided with her a bit and I don't
blame him uh you know I did I had to go
to court several times to uh battle
claims that I was had in dangered the
life of the minor
child uh just because I took him scuba
diving without a tank and let him budy
dive off my tank and we get into court
and he goes home and and the sharks
out of Catalina and uh said guys someone
told his said don't tell your mother
about this said guys first he tells his
mother yeah he says dad put some weight
put a big weight belt on me and then we
dive off together and he went down there
sharks everywhere and he just gave me
the breathing when I could breathe like
this and so I get to court on that one
and the judge says well
are you a qualified scuba diver
instructor I said no so let me get this
right you take your son diving without
the right equipment and you're not even
a scuba diver
instructor so I got a ration for that
one then I took him to Australia in the
bush where I'm from and showed him how
he used to live and he ended up in
hospital for that for dehydration
because he wouldn't drink anything cuz
it was dead cattle in the water hole I
said well that doesn't matter I said
look the the dead cattle are there we
can drink out of there
okay that didn't work at all what would
you say is your greatest
strength um
resilience I just I believe in go no
matter what
go and you can fall on your ass you can
uh make
mistakes but from every time you fall
and from every mistake you learn
something and you don't fall the same
way twice you don't make the same M
mistake
twice but uh the thing is to get up off
the canvas and
go what are your thoughts clearly you
are not risk
averse and what what what are your
thoughts on taking risks in life risk is
as necessary in life as the air you
breathe if you don't take a
risk then you don't Excel your whole
spirit and body to its to its extent and
the more risk you take the better off
you are because risk pumps adrenaline
adrenaline pumps your body that pumps
your brain it pumps your whole being
without risk you are nobody without risk
you might as well sit on the couch and
get fat and
die but risk is risk is everything it's
not something it's everything yeah I I
think risk I think adrenaline is a
secret ingredient in doing great things
in life there's so many so many things
that we're scared to do and and when you
just sit there on your sofa and think
about it you're not going to do it it's
too it's too daunting but when the
moment when the moment comes when that
woman comes in your life or that
opportunity comes in your life and and
that risk needs to be taken adrenaline
will get you through it yes you youve
you've adrenaline is is what pumps our
heart what pumps our Spirit without that
we are nobody and you have to take risks
I ride horses every other day and I find
the steepest nastiest thing I can find
and I don't feel I'd ridden unless I
feel a heart Tu oh go wow that was that
was good you know what I mean so you got
to you got to take risk without risk
it's nothing life is
nothing um just
meeting that girl across there you got
to take the risk that she's going to
tell you no you're an idiot you got to
take you might go over and she say oh
that's interesting yeah so but you got
to take the risk you can't because risk
is a false narrative because what are
you taking a risk for you're risking a
result well you you're here you're not
over there where you can get the result
you don't know what the result is so the
idea of risk is
totally totally without Merit put it
that way and when you take a risk and
you achieve it and I ride horses and I
find really steep rough country that
gives me a heart thump and if i' if I've
got if I look at something I say can I
do that I can't do it I want to say yeah
I can do it and once I've had that
discussion with myself I can't go away
cuz I'd get over there 10 ft away and
say you're a coward you're an absolute
coward you walked away from that what
sort of person are you I have have this
conversation with myself you have to
live with yourself the rest you're going
to do it
okay that's what you got to do and if
you do that you'll you'll I'm 81 years
old I went to had a medical uh uh 3
months ago I have a heavy duty truck
driver's license I don't know why I can
drive semis but I don't drive semis but
I just like the idea of having it um and
the doctor looked at my
chart while I'm going to his medic he
called his associate and he says hey
look at this the associate looked at the
figures he looked at me and he says uh
you know he says you have the blood
pressure of a high school athlete I said
what do you do I said everything I can
possibly
he said we'll keep doing
it that's great all right Colin thank
you so much for sharing your story yeah
I wish you lots of
luck